yo
[Música]
llegó el día en que en sólo dos años de
trabajo firme y decidido en este senado
de la republica podremos acabar con 100
años de prohibición innecesaria en estos
dos años de labores hemos construido un
dictamen que vela por el libre
desarrollo de la personalidad por la
salud de mexicanas y mexicanos y por el
bienestar de toda la nación manifestamos
en contra
de que si se liberalice la venta de
drogas en este caso marihuana en nuestro
país cuando vamos a votar una reforma
siempre nos preguntamos si eso le va a
traer algo positivo al país o no y sin
duda alguna en este caso nosotros
consideramos que no no consideramos que
sea positivo y que esté al alcance de
nuestros jóvenes adolescentes y también
niños
porque es un avance social
en una transición
en la cual nos encontramos el día de hoy
es algo que también nos preocupan los
consumidores toda la gente que vemos
aquí en el día de hoy
pues creo que comparten la idea de no
dejar sus derechos vulnerarse no por la
autoridad que está para protegernos no
para encarcelar para anunciar como vende
un medicamento o una aspirina
no no no no no lo tomamos estamos
vendiendo marihuana
lo tomamos como un producto más de la
farmacia
[Música]
la marihuana tampoco es gran parte de mi
vida creo que hay que establecer límites
y espero que todo el mundo lo respete
tanto fumadores como no fumadores
en la marihuana enrachado de tal manera
que todo el crimen organizado de toda
europa está viniendo a españa en
concreto a cataluña porque porque
cataluña es lo que nosotros no miramos
el huerto de europa porque estamos
produciendo la mayoría de marihuana
[Música]
aquí en dakota del sur en los últimos
años el 10 por ciento de todos los
arrestos que se hicieran en el estado
fueron por marihuana y la mayoría de
esos arrestos fueron por unos pocos
gramos de cannabis así que tenemos un
problema real aquí donde hemos
criminalizado a toda una generación de
habitantes de dakota del sur y estamos
pagando un alto precio por eso pero en
el mundo entero de las personas que
necesitan cuidados paliativos del final
de la vida solamente el 10% lo está
recibiendo y muchas veces por falta de
tratamiento aquí tenemos una alternativa
barata eficaz y segura como para ir a
dar respuesta a esta demanda humanitaria
porque finalmente eso
[Música]
el cannabis no es una planta que se
pueda usar sin cuidado es algo que debe
respetarse el cannabis es una planta muy
respetada no es algo que solo se fume es
algo que ayuda a los curanderos a curar
a las personas se cocina y se consume
cuando tienes problemas en el pecho o la
presión alta se lo damos para bajar su
presión arterial para que pueda estar
bien
[Música]